playing small friend
no berserking
oh what did people want me to play
I think I'll play E4
ah yeah there was a request earlier
about the Danish
okay Dana's gambits
Adidas Gambit isn't usually
so popular at like higher levels
um there's a few lines that are
considered to equalize for black but it
still can lead to some fun positions
we have Danish Gambit accepted
we also have Google Bouche with the raid
guten Aben to Germany or maybe Guten
Morgen
also how do you say Happy New Year in
German
yeah shout out to Google I'm trying to
remember my the German names for all the
pieces
loifa Springer
dhamma
Koenig
Pawn
why why am I failing Pawn
pieshka
oh boa boa or Bower boa
thanks to all the people who speak
German and chapter
helping me remember
wow so Knight C6
like the theoretical move is D5 and
Danish
Knight C6 is um
kind of accepting the fact that
box not gonna like force
simplification
uh yeah just to show with arrows the
main line is D5 takes minus six
takes takes takes and then Bishop B4
wins back the queen and
um there's some known ending which is
close to equal
[Music]
but it would be nice if we don't trade
Queens early
I think you like yeah
says things for the games and for
helping me sleep my pleasure
thank you Mr ash brown first time sub
okay
um yeah this is like a true Danish
wow I really want to take in the 95
probably doesn't work
and there's Queen B3
Queen B3 Queen E7
all right well if I take and then this
like H6 is very
it's provoking me to go a little bit
crazy
and visual seven king of seven Queen
here
of King G6 Queen F5 King yid I've moved
here if King seven I mean King E7 has to
be played at some point
and then now they try threatening Knight
G6
I think I just go for it
I've already sacked two Pawns
now I'm sacking a bishop
now the drawback of H6 was um it's very
weakening to the square and
the main problem this sign is when I
play Queen H5 after King Yates black
doesn't have the usual G6
so King's gonna have to
move to E7 now it's still not over
this may have been like objectively
dubious for me
but that's so interesting
pants late night wife alert
I wonder if you're related to there's
another account my wife is a lawyer
the things for the 23 months
appreciate that
okay forcing King E7
I really want to play like Bishop A3 but
then this move
foreign
was my original idea
now I'm realizing it's not so simple
after Queen E8
hmm
oh actually Knight C3 looks very simple
because Knight C3 at first I wasn't sure
about Queen E8 but I just checked King d
a take take and win The Rook
and it's hard for black to win back
material
let's play Knight C3
and yeah this move should be prioritized
because it brings in another piece
it's all about having more manpower
or light power
so I'm down the bishop and the pawn
I'm so glad whoever suggested the Danish
Gambit things for the suggestion
I'm happy that my small friend is
gone into
like the trickiest line for black
yeah so we might see Knight F6
and then I still play Knight D5
and black would probably have to take
take
and the knight's a bit uh questionable
there are cases it's probably very
unlikely but
maybe what's more likely is check
I'm already fantasizing about amplus on
checkmates
in the line after Knight F6 Knight T5
takes takes for example Knight B8 Bishop
A3 C5
but it's not quite made
what's the Omega Gambit
is that when you just Spam Omega LOL in
chat
and then get banned
and dubious compensation
okay so we're getting the sign also
what's up Gary happy New Year tagari
shadow tagari
hope you're doing well
this is such a fun position
the king cannot retreat
and after takes takes e-files then very
open
so there's how many legal moves one two
three legal moves for black
I'm not sure what I would do here this
Buck I'd probably also take some time
sometimes it's a matter of process of
elimination like you you look at all
your legal moves and you see which ones
lose immediately
and then you choose the one that maybe
isn't so obviously losing
wow
okay
we're about to have some fun
or are we where's my
where's my check
I want to play this but then king of
seven
if Knight F4 the king returns
there's a lot to fantasize about here
so Knight F4
wait another four king U7 Knight G6 here
check
um not seeing the force meet looks
really close so
I also start with Bishop takes off F6
but maybe I'll play that after King E7
no King E7 I take and then okay some
Fork
or
if this move I mean there's some
potential for castling with mate
that's not immediately made but be
really close if this move I mean E5
okay no mercy here
so if I think it's actually force made
here
if King takes
then
95 King E6
Queen F5 King G6 the king might be a
little bit slippery
it's really close though
if Pawn takes
I'm still Knight D5
there's a lot of funny lines
actually context I play Knight G6
and King F7 and Knight E5
a king moves this way it's mate King
moves This Way Queen F7 King G6
I'm looking for the castling with mate
yeah too much fun at that point
okay so let's go for this one
check
yeah I'm controlling the squares
uh for the king to retreat to so
slightly the kingal side step
and then check
attack
uh E5
not so obvious
I'll try this once
King C5
opponent will probably end up flagging
or taking a lot of time here
uh
yeah let's repeat
we'll try and finish off in style at
least
oh no my Knights
oh yes my castle check
not quite a castle mate
did I sack my Rook now
wait the king's kind of escaping
how's this happening
oh there's a funny line look at the sign
check
oh no my Rook
I think this is the best move too and
then Pawn check now the king can't
really
move to where it wanted to move to
don't flag oh no
a now check
and meet next move
okay
how many things did I sack that game
final position I'm down the Rook two
Bishops and the pawn
that may have been the one of the more
efficient ways to win too
real quick I'll analyze
oh that was so nice
this might call for a standalone YouTube
video
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
I hope you're inspired to play the
Danish also wait what
minus 6.9
I'm losing here
I thought it was force mate
King C4
King C4 is winning for black no
no
[Music]
92.
King B4
A3
King A4 is winning for black that's
insane
that's really crazy
as losing here I was casting Queen side
wow
if I don't play E6 and find the maiden 9
at least find the first move for Maiden
nine then white is much worse
so what's amazing night E6
King G6
and then Castle Queen side
ah and then yeah then just have too much
fun
95
King B5 Queen B1
this is how the engine finishes things
off and then sacked The Rook
and then deliver me like this
I've Miss made into really
oh I had made in two
ah
oops
yeah that would have been a little bit
smoother
I played this thinking like everything
would win
okay that was a funny finish was Bishop
Bishop 7 had to be
oh it wasn't good
really
King E7
ah no I don't have this
and if this then Queenie Yates yeah
okay I could have been much worse there
but the the dubiousness paid off
I think that was still YouTube Worthy
on people in the YouTube comments can
criticize me if they want